there and hopefully we don't get booted
from the finals ladies and gentlemen how
does that even happen the guy who makes
the room gets booted and doesn't get to
see what's what what are you talking
about into endo here we go ladies
gentlemen blank and pretty Roger blank
switching it up going away from his main
normally he's a peach humane switching
it up going with Donkey Kong the grand
vitals ladies and gentlemen should I
turn on my broadcasting voice here turn
on my broadcasting boys we've got blank
here with an early 52% advantage pretty
Roger does have him up to 31% Donkey
Kong one of the more powerful heavy
characters in this game he's got a lot
of great moves a lot of great aerial
moves the back air in particular is
really nice for Donkey Kong an insane
number of spikes as well
it's get it on indeed I said I should
have had that queued up
ooh pretty Roger though just like that
hasn't my 45 are you kidding me are you
kidding me with that Blake
holy moly what a move at a hundred forty
five percent damn it's just when he
thought pretty Roger was about to score
the ko
Blanc sent him flying town it's at 173
though he needs to take advantage of
this he needs to take advantage of this
lead and he knows it he wants to get
some damage there he goes gets his 12%
blocks the next move but our buddy
mr. toad mr. toad comes out there with
the deflect move and sends him flying
since it flying oh man this is gonna be
good guys this is gonna be good
blink with another ko there reminder
they both agree that's gonna be best of
five lasers on the best of five years
pretty Roger we've seen both of these
characters dominate blank and pretty
Roger regardless of who they came up
against they've dominated this whole
entire tournament now let's see how
pretty Roger can adjust now that he's
been behind we've never seen him behind
before quite like this donkey call corn
for the back here spinning off stage
buddy just misses it he loses a stock
off of that he loses the stock with the
adjustment from pre Roger
[Applause]
and one more time for good measure
let's go guys let's go
more of that please more of that GG
looks like Blanc might be switching up
characters here well looks like he might
be switching up characters we'll see I
think he is or is it or is it more mind
games here is it more mind games blanks
got the 1o lead right now are you
kidding me are you kidding me he goes
with the random
it goes with the Randleman he got Luigi
he's saying come at me say come at me
pretty Roger I'm gonna go with Luigi I'm
gonna go with a random character we
don't know who's gonna turn up and he's
got the artery right here dude I'm so
hyped right now you guys can't tell in
case you guys can't tell oh pretty Roger
though pretty Roger says don't forget
don't forget what got me here
no no we got some good matches right now
I'm sorry sorry Spotify
alright guys pretty Roger but best of
five now say doesn't have to have this
victory but he doesn't want to get down
to Oh
cuz now I want to get down to oh is that
one hundred three percent right now but
he does have Luigi already back up to
102 percent he's got to turn up now
either character can be ko'd right now
where they're at both over 100 percent
damage pretty Roger went for the grab
missed it there good blank look at blank
look at blank with Luigi it's caught in
a little too close right there
he's got the tournament and she's got
the back throw
oh oh oh - - on stock but Luigi's had
150 percent damage pretty Roger nice
toad coming in with the assist right
there
blanks able to get back on stage though
she gets the grab that's probably gonna
be a yes and be pretty Roger with a 2-1
lead right now in this in this set keep
in mind guys blank went with a random
you were with a random on this kinda
show his true Millie saying I can play
with anyone in the game can play with
anyone in a ball game this is so intense
at 110% but he's still getting damaged
while offstage and there's the maybe
maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe yeah
that's gonna do it
pretty Roger even things up in this
best-of-five series evens it up in the
best-of-five series blank with LOL in
the chat he did indeed folks go with a
completely random character he went
completely random let's see what he
decides to do this time kinda search
it's be honest flying cops out he's
gonna switch characters again let's see
what's up here we'll see what's up to go
random again now the things are evened
up pretty Roger staying focused staying
focused on Daisy so far
who pulls out the captain falcon pulls
out the captain falcon you see them use
ganondorf earlier but i've not yet seen
his captain falcon obviously very
similar characters but captain Falcons
got the speed d roger behind the
eight-ball early at 39% damage here in
the middle of a best-of-five series each
opponent here taken one game already and
by far guys these have been the two
probably strongest players in the
tournament that we've seen thus far and
then they just they end up against each
other here at the end you couldn't have
asked for a better better finals
honestly this your first time checking
out the stream welcome thank you so much
for stopping by
my name is jonathan and is channel is
all about stories about my stories about
your story stories we share together the
stories of our lives and how we can
improve improve this we're all the
positivity with twitch with video games
some people say it's just switch just
games you know doesn't mean anything oh
I completely disagree I've seen twitch
I've seen video games change people's
lives change people's lives for the
better and right now we are celebrating
one year of streaming and hopefully of
impacting lives for the better I'm not
I'm not gonna say they've changed
anybody's life here but I do hope that
when you come here on and check out the
stream that you enjoy it nice back air
right there from blank he gets the early
KO but he is at 164 percent these guys
just just dead even in this fight so far
just dead even
there he goes pretty Roger back in its
the KO but he is already at 65% blank
with a very nice job of making that
advantage account right then not
settling staying aggressive goes for the
Falcon kick for a little edge guarding
here pretty Rogers able to recover get
back on stage he's got the turnip now
you just look at the - look at the mind
games able to get to turn him off the
hit there again both over a hundred
percent damage for this stock connects
in air with Falcons up B get the next ko
on pretty Roger pretty roger though got
him off stage here and he's hasn't take
any damage on this stock yet there he
goes they're gonna KO and though I don't
believe so and he gets him well he's
having on the ledge right there
dude what a fight what a fight dead even
here in the final stock
oh pretty bad you're getting in close
get in the combo game going get him a
cabo get going quickly blank had the
advantage earlier pretty Roger as came
storming back in this have to Falcon
over hundred percent
neither of these competitors guys
neither of them afraid to go off stage
even early in the stock even at the
damage look at this look at this
it doesn't KO her pretty roger not kod
gets back 99 percent to 112 right now
captain falcon though and that's gonna
be the game what a battle
oh my goodness guys whoo blank takes the
2-1 lead remember we changed things it
is best-of-five here for the grand
finals ladies and gentlemen that's the
five here for the grand finals what a
match
what a match blank hopping out again
hopping out again could be changing
characters once more we've seen me use
it a different character for every fight
that almost finish was incredible I
agree Raven that was that was insane it
looked like Roger had the advantage had
him offstage and Falcon hit the lb it
looked like he had the advantage and
then it oh it was great
all right now so blank told us earlier
pichu is his main so here going for the
victory he switches to his name if blank
wins ladies gentlemen he is the winner
of the $25 and the winner of the first
ever retro racket or smash brothers
tournament if pretty Roger wins we work
we will go to a game 5 to decide the
champion pretty Roger here showing an
advantage early against the Picchu 115
percent damage and Blake's not going to
get back from that
only at 14% Roger turning up his game
here he knows he's got to have this one
now blank making the adjustment making
the adjustment with his peach you as it
played peach you yet against pretty
Roger at all
still looking pretty even right now
though pretty Roger has the advantage in
stock
that was a great person a great match
right there Jamal I agree
Pichu goes off stage is that gonna do it
is that gonna do it no it is not pretty
Roger gets back on stage I'm gonna reset
this thing back to neutral we go at the
turnabout I'd able to connect their feet
use attacks dude they're just so good
they're so good it's damage though it's
not gonna take much to KO Pichu
and for that matter Daisy even there it
is maybe maybe maybe Oh No
eros I saw the future their customer
gets the grab and she's gonna get the
quick no nope nope nope now quick ko
blank nose right now blanks playing with
house money playing with house money
he's got a he's got a two to one lead in
the overall tournament and he's down in
this stock honestly blank just now
switching over to his mean he could just
use this match to kind of feel things
out knowing that he that he could
actually lose this is he gonna get
pretty Roger down to one stock though
that's the question right now it's him
off stage he's only at 45% not that much
if he's able to get the KO here just
missed it just missed it
reset the fight once again as they head
back to center stage blank knocks him
off there look at the dance look at the
dance smash brothers at times once you
really start to kind of understand
understand the mechanics but just looks
like a back and forth dance all right
guys
pretty Roger down to his final stock he
needs this win to extend this tournament
he needs the win if Blanc wins he is our
champion he's got a bit of a
disadvantage right now he's at 91% but
he's quickly accumulating damage on
pretty Roger here already up to 41%
I wanted to go to Game five I wanted to
go to Game five sorry blank I want to
see a game five oh no oh no oh no he
gets the grab throws him offstage
he said one hundred thirty two percent
though Pichu any little thing is gonna
knock him off but he's quickly got Daisy
to 86 percent knows for the spike goes
for the spike with the downbeat right
there just missed it man you can tell
pretty Roger three Roger on the
defensive here that's gonna do it that's
gonna do it like with comeback guys
don't need to see me for now
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please say
congratulations to your champion Blanc
one three five five five with his Picchu
he wins it
[Music]